all right here's a theory I've been
thinking about uh someday maybe not next
year or five or even 10 years but maybe
someday we'll all live in a world where
we all have these wearable computers on
our faces all the time and a lot of
these tech companies really believe in
that future like I've never spoken to
anyone on planet Earth who believes more
than Mark Zuckerberg that humans are on
their way to spending tons of their time
in some sort of metaverse but the tech
is clearly not good enough yet today in
2023 for anyone to want to do that like
this is what a VR headset looks like in
2023 and this is the best we've got and
even now the computers and pixels and
batteries and everything on your face
are too much for people to want to spend
all day in something like this but we're
all kind of on board that maybe someday
the tech will shrink down more and more
and more and more until eventually it's
no more than just a normal looking pair
of glasses and then maybe at that point
well I'll be cool wearing it every day
so this Quest three this newest and
latest and great headset from meta my
theory is is on this side of the scale
and on the other side of the sliding
scale is smart glasses and meta
literally is also announcing smart
glasses at their event so these things
are literally called the Rayban meta
smart glasses aka the Rayband stories 2o
right now they are super simple they
don't do much because they can only fit
a camera and small speakers and a
battery but there are some clever tricks
that enable them to do as much as
possible and maybe someday the tech will
get power enough and useful enough for
people to want to use these every day so
VR headsets are racing to get smaller
and smaller and smart glasses are racing
to get better and better Tech and
they're both basically racing towards
each other and companies like meta are
spending tons and tons of money to
develop these things to figure out which
strategy will hit first so let's see
let's start with the headset so this is
the latest and greatest from meta the
quest 3 and this is the year they made
their big pivot to it being a mixed
reality headset which in hindsight feels
like a natural progression for these
things if you want to get them more
comfortable for people to wear everyday
like glasses so in previous VR headsets
it really felt like pass through was an
afterthought like you put the headset on
and you're just immediately in your own
world until you take the headset off and
this new version is still built to be
immersive it still has all the light
blocking and fills your field of view
with screens and makes it as immersive
as possible but it now has a bunch more
sensors arranged around the outside that
make passed through dramatically better
than before it's now color stereo very
low latency and decently high resolution
and there's immediately a bunch of
benefits to having pass through being
this good first of all the setup was way
more intuitive like you can literally
take it to a new spot for the first time
and just put it on it boots up and
automatically you look down and it just
Maps out the floor of the room you're in
the available floor space the objects in
the room the spots where you can stand
and to surprisingly great accuracy so
it's using a pair of RGB cameras and the
light R sensor in the middle so you no
longer have to painstakingly draw a play
area every single time and stick with it
it just naturally feels like it plants
the menu floating right in the middle of
where you're standing and you can still
see everything around you now you may be
wondering okay how good though like
exactly is the quest 3 is it the best is
it is it better than the quest
Pro yes it's better than Quest Pro but
it is not as good as Apple Vision Pro I
would kind of equate it to like if I
gave you a clear pair of glasses that
were not exactly your prescription but
basically this one's good because it's
stereo and color and nearly real time so
you see accurate colors you look at your
hands and you can find the controllers
wherever they are in the room just pick
them up and put them down without
needing someone to hand them to you just
so many benefits like that there's also
just a small amount of distortion with
up close objects and things near the
edges of your vision but it's not quite
high enough Fidelity to like pick up
your phone and start using that screen
so like if you get a text you're still
gonna have to take the headset off to be
able to read it and I know comparing it
to a $3,500 headset feels unnecessary
and it kind of is but also a lot of
people have asked me about it and I am
one of a few people who can actually say
they've tried both so I will say that
yes Apple Vision Pro is still the best
pass through I've ever experienced I
distinctly remember taking notes about
my experience on my phone while still
wearing the headset it was kind of
insane but for a $500 headset yeah this
is absolutely as good as you're going to
see and combined with the high
resolution of the actual menus and the
accuracy of the controllers it's I think
it's pretty awesome and then of course
the other benefit to having way higher
quality sensors around the outside of
the headset is you don't actually need
the controllers now you've always had
the choice to either use the controllers
or use your hands uh and these
controllers have gotten better over the
years they're smaller they're pretty
sweet they have better haptics than ever
before but the hand tracking has also
gotten way better and really intuitive
and responsive responsive and I think
this is key again to feeling like the
future so you do this pinch gesture here
to pull up the menu and move around to
select things you can literally scroll
around menus by touching the digital
menu and flinging them through space
with your finger or you can grab a
window and just move it around putting
it on a table or floating it in the air
and it just stays locked there which is
pretty awesome so pretty much everything
except typing is is natural it works as
you'd expect like you're typing on a
virtual keyboard floating in space but
this will definitely take more practice
because there's no haptic feedback see
the other gestures I was talking about
almost always have a haptic feedback of
your own fingers hitting each other
which is really interesting uh this
keyboard here you're sort of just poking
an invisible plane in the air where the
keyboard should be so that that's a
little tougher the main selling point of
this headset though is still playing
games that's still what it's super good
at and it plays all the same games that
the Quest 2 could play and there are
even some games optimized for Quest 3
that it's even better at it has this
nextg Qualcomm Snapdragon xr2 chip it
has higher resolution per eye it has a
wider more immersive field of view and
it's in my opinion slightly more
comfortable thanks to this new strap
that improves weight distribution so
I've been playing a bunch I I've really
enjoyed this golf game that feels
surprisingly realistic as someone that
was expecting like wi golf levels of
graphics and control also pingpong which
this has this eie multiplayer mode
online where someone else's Avatar just
shows up in your space standing 10 ft
away from you but with no legs uh but
you know the classics like beat saber
super hot and then even some new ones
like gorilla tag is blowing up all this
stuff is the main reason why today you'd
buy something like this to spend like
half an hour in the thing but again the
tech is shrinking down more and more and
more and will every single year until it
gets close to something like these smart
glasses so let's talk about the smart
glasses so these are the meta smart
glasses and and there's others like it
but they're going to start at the other
end of the spectrum where there's only
so much stuff that you can stuff stuff
into a regular looking pair of glasses
that nobody would even look twice at but
over time as Tech gets better and more
powerful and more miniaturized these
things will get more and more powerful
and more and more able to do more stuff
so right now this is a 12 megapixel
camera with a little LED light ring to
indicate when it's recording or taking a
picture a shutter button on top and then
a literal computer inside with some
storage a touchpad on the side and then
some microphones and then these really
tiny pinhole speakers that Fire audio
downwards directly into your ears it
doesn't sound like much but when paired
directly to your phone and The Meta view
app this thing is surprisingly capable
as a little computer on your face so you
can use the camera of course to just
take firstperson pictures and videos
just by hitting the shutter button
videos are limited to 60 seconds or less
and portrait orientation but honestly
despite all that they're actually pretty
solid looking videos and there's some
promise here I kind of feel like I might
want to use these for autofocus for like
car driving footage if I could get
widescreen out of them that would be
awesome and then you can also start a
recording or take a picture just by
saying hey meta take a
picture and so you can see that it was
pretty fast the the little light there
uh I don't know if you want to say that
phrase out loud very often so you might
just stick to one of these but yeah it
has a voice assistant built in so you
can send and receive messages through
WhatsApp Messenger you know meta stuff
but it's just audio like there's no
screen anywhere in here built so this
this really works best with experiences
that can be entirely handled with just
audio so they're connected all the time
to your phone via Bluetooth so you can
listen to music and these little
speakers are directional enough that at
half volume there's really not that much
bleed and that high volume it kind of
just sounds the same as someone like
maybe listening next to you with open
back
headphones that's as loud as it gets but
you can also
ask questions of the meta virtual
assistant little AI virtual assistant
built into the computers in this little
pair of glasses and you have to ask it
hey meta what's the weather tomorrow and
then it reads the answers directly into
your
ears and so now I know it's going to
rain for our last practice of the Year
great we can also ask it random
questions about people uh asked it to
write a poem and it gave me a poem it's
Internet connected from your phone so it
can do a bunch of stuff uh for fun I
asked it to write a acceptance speech
for me as I walk onto stage wearing the
sunglasses and by the time I got on
stage I can start saying an acceptance
speech as it's reading them into my ears
which I thought was that's kind of a fun
hack so this is all based on meta's new
llama 2 language model so it's pretty
fluid and you don't have to rely on
saying certain specific phrases to get
it to keep going through the
conversation now you know it's not the
best AI assistant I've ever heard and it
still has its limitations it still can't
set alarms or access third third party
services that aren't meta but the fact
that I could be on a phone call right
now and you wouldn't even notice in
public that's kind of the point there's
uh two different styles by rayb Band for
these These are the headliner and the W
farer the downside is is very clearly
battery life I mean this is a small
small battery to fit in here so it's
cool that you have this wireless
charging case so the second you take
them off you can just put them in the
case and charge them back up just like
earbuds basically so it's more about how
many times the case can charge them up
honestly on one charge if I listen to a
bunch of music and take a bunch of
pictures and videos I can kill these
things in under 2 hours but they're
quoting 36 total hours of battery life
with the charging case by the way the
recording light is on one side but then
it's the camera on the other side so
that keeps it nice and symmetrical like
normal glasses should be but that's the
idea this is about as much Tech as you
can fit in a normal looking pair of
glasses in
2023 without it starting stting to look
weird with the current Tech we have but
it's going to be more and more and more
stuff and still looking like this every
year so the question is which side would
you bet gets Mass adoption first and
this is a question tech companies have
to answer before they start investing
now meta is invested in both so maybe
they win either way and they're they're
involved but if you're Snapchat they've
already tried just the smart glasses and
maybe they'll keep doing that later uh
if you're Apple they've clearly started
with apple vision and they're going to
try to miniaturize that and Shrink that
year after year but which side and what
a time to be alive for all this cuz the
tech that we're going to have on our
faces in 10 20 years is going to look
insane compared to what we have today
the same way that the tech we had 10
years ago looks archaic compared to what
we have now so all that being said I'll
leave you with this one Quest three for
500 bucks is awesome and if you're
looking to get a VR headset or a mixed
reality headset at all no problem
recommending this one it's pretty sweet
sweet two Apple's Vision Pro is still on
track to be released early 2024 and I
think it's going to be pretty awesome so
make sure you get subscribed to see the
review of that when it happens and
three I'm pretty sure we are barreling
towards this computers on our faces
future at some point it does feel like
it's picking up that much Steam and that
much investment so even if you don't
believe we're are going to be wearing
these on our faces for a super long time
it probably won't be this it'll be
something smaller and slowly we'll get
more and more face computer time
so which side do you pick thanks for
watching catch you in the next one
peace